- This way, guys.
Hey, hey. We don’t do that anymore.
Tables are for...
- Studying film.
- Howdy, Jon! How’s your culture change going?
- I tell you what, man, things are finally calming down around he—WHOA.
- BOSSSAAAAA BRUH?!?
- Them Bosa Boys are terrorizing Gridiron Heights, man!
- WOOOOOO.
- Aw, Odell, help!
- Hehehe.
- DON'T YOU DARE RUIN MY JAY-Z PHOTOSHOOT.
- Now the only way to stop bad brothers is with good brothers.
- Not you, Jay.
- Watt residence, to what charity can I write the check?
Thanks for coming to talk sense into them, McCourty Twins.
- No.
- Problem.
- They’re playing on the edge.
- 🎶Ninety-nine quarterbacks to hit on the line, ninety-nine quarterbacks to hit— 🎶
- Guys, defenders should be nice and marketable.
- Do we scare you?
- Yeah, is that an offensive player I see?
- Derek, run.
T.J., on my—
- I ALSO LIVE ON THE EDGE, J.J.!
- Uhhh, Uhhh.
- THEY CANNOT BE CONTAINED. HIDE YOUR QBS!
- Who is it?
- Josh Allen.
- Oh phew…
- THE OTHER JOSH ALLEN.
- AHHHHHHHH!!
- If you.
- Liked
- This video
- Subscribe below
- For more.
- Or we’re not
- Jason
- And Jason McCourtey.
- No, you’re Devin.
- I’m pretty sure you’re Devin.
- Which of us is Devin?
- Uh, you!
- ME?
- I’ll be Devin.
- Thanks Jason.